we begin the day with those skyrocketing
numbers of new coronavirus infections
and the recycled recommendations and new
mandates being launched to drive those
numbers down earlier this week in the
u.s the centers for disease control
backpedaled on face masks recommending
again that people
wear masks indoors with one important
difference
this recommendation is for vaccinated
people
it comes amid worries that the vaccine
may not be able to protect in crowds of
unvaccinated people
who may be carrying the more
transmissible delta variant
public health officials here in europe
and in the u.s
are urging people not to wait any longer
to get
their shots in the u.s the number of new
people willing to be vaccinated
has stagnated now this is important
because the unvaccinated
comprise almost all hospitalizations and
covet 19
deaths public health officials are
calling this the pandemic
of the unvaccinated with the vaccine
available practically everywhere in the
united states
patients with those refusing to get the
jab
is wearing very thin angelinos have
stayed home for over
a year to protect themselves and each
other and quite frankly i think it's
safe to say that we're getting tired of
protecting people who don't want to
protect themselves
or get vaccinated we have three vaccines
readily available that are effective
we have vaccine events across our city
we have accessible vaccine centers and
even we've gone door to door
offering the vaccine shots yet we still
have people endangering themselves and
others
this is truly a pandemic of the
unvaccinated
well for more now we want to bring in
eric feingolding he's an epidemiologist
and a senior fellow at the federation of
american
scientists eric it's good to see you
again talk to me
what effect is a a face mask
mandate for all u.s federal employees
what impact is that going to have
well face mask plus a vaccine mandate
would be
huge because the federal employee
and the contractors is the number one
largest employer in the united states
so that would automatically sweep a lot
of people
under the masking and under vaccinations
and
you know the vaccines it's actually more
of an attestation not a
true hard mandate because you just need
to confirm that you have been vaccinated
and if not you have to wear a mask um
and get tested regularly
but this is huge because this is a
precedent setting to send signals to
businesses
many businesses are now following suit
of requiring it
walt disney world also just announced um
people are visiting their parks
as well this is a really game changer
and hopefully hopefully this will create
the tide that will
eventually get majority of businesses up
and states also complying well eric how
did the united states get to this point
the u.s
has been one of the leaders in
vaccinations and now it has been
overtaken by the european union
why has that lead slipped
yeah it's really been the tale of the
tortoise and the hair
um and the us has been the hair in terms
of
coming out very quickly with
vaccinations and rollouts
but then it's we've hit the vaccine
hesitancy wall
um you could say in which there's a
large fraction
30 percent in the u.s that's just
resistant to taking
any vaccine shots and many of them not
getting the second vaccine shots as well
the us is
kind of stuck around like um you know
upper 50 60
60 percent uh vaccinated and
there's many other european countries in
which there is
less misinformation there's still
misinformation in europe
too but the misinformation in the
right-wing um
you know anti-vaccine misinformal
machine
has been really really much more
aggressive in the us
and i think right now this is the again
the back the pandemic of the
unvaccinated
but also which in which if you're
vaccinated and you're not masked
it also allows the virus to keep
spreading
so we even among those who are
vaccinated must take precautions and the
cdc
has been you know had two months of
allowing vaccinated people to not wear
mass and even despite who's urging
and now it's coming home to roost and
the delta various surgeon
i'd like you to listen to what the
governor of the alabama kate ivey what
she
said this week almost 100
of the new hospitalizations are with
unvaccinated folks
and the deaths are certainly
occurring with unvaccinated folks these
folks are choosing
a horrible lifestyle
of self-inflicted pain you know we've
got to get folks
to take the shot the vaccine is the
greatest weapon we have to fight kobe
there's no question about that
so she's saying there we've got to get
people to to get vaccinated now
it's just come across that president
biden
is asking the states to offer the
unvaccinated
a hundred dollars to get their
shots what do you make of that a hundred
dollars to get vaccinated
yeah i think 100 is a great start and
the funding is already there
the issue is we've had lotteries of a
million dollars we've had
many other bonuses uh that
we've dangled we've tried almost every
single
carrot uh that we had to get people
vaccinated
and people are just not budging the the
low-hanging fruits of people willing
have already or
taken the shot so in certain ways we
have to resort
to sticks with mandates or these
pressure points
of of facts potentially vaccine access
uh passes that kind of francis
implemented for indoor dining
we have to urge them and a mandate is
really necessary
and by the way we have mandates for
other things seat belt mandates
uh bike helmet mandates we also have a
mandate that you do not drink and drive
it is not about freedom it is about
public safety
all of those laws and we do them even if
the hospital beds are not full as well
so in certain ways public health really
really is the paramount that mandates
are
necessary and they're not infringing on
freedom especially if
you giving off the virus endangers
someone else
your right to endanger other people ends
in my nose and that's why
these measures are necessary
you